I wish no I take both of you tonight you
better lie I can't put it down
an officer-involved shooting is now
under investigation in Tennessee after
police respond to multiple 9-1-1 calls
about a man wielding a weapon
I'm on River Road about a mile from
Cumberland Heights and there's a man I
don't know if he has a stick a gun and
he's like waving it out on the road it
happened on Saturday November 12th in
Nashville Tennessee between 4 45 and 6
o'clock that evening multiple 9-1-1
calls came in for a man walking
alongside the road some callers believed
he was carrying a weapon and others
reported he threw things at their
vehicles he's still
um like in the same area but now he is
throwing prelims at cars in the road
we've had two calls about him um one he
hit her car and she just kept going
because she's like terrified of it yeah
and the next one the same thing six
minutes after the last 9-1-1 call was
made two officers with the Metropolitan
Nashville Police Department responded to
the scene
what are you doing a body camera video
shows the officers approaching the man
asking him about the situation
I don't call me a guy screaming my life
I'm solving himself my bitches down in
my you illegal for one night so I know
you breaking my law what you need to do
my life I don't know how you live your
life who you pay for God gave him all
right all right you ain't taking it no I
ain't saying nothing you need it boy
local media Outlets identify the man as
64 year old Brandon John Brown the
Metropolitan Nashville police department
has not yet confirmed the suspect's name
all right so what's going on tonight
stand over here with me come on walk
with me walk with you yeah walk with me
all right body cam video shows officers
continue to work with the suspect who
ignores their commands eventually one
officer deploys a taser twice in an
effort to secure the situation
sir put that down put that down Taser
Taser after that the man charges at
officers that's when multiple shots are
fired
shots fired shots fired sir drop the
knife the suspect was pronounced dead at
the scene neither of the officers
involved were injured the Tennessee
Bureau of Investigation is now
conducting a use of force investigation
into the shooting the Davidson County
District Attorney's office and the
Metropolitan Nashville police department
will also conduct investigations for the
latest developments in this story and
all things True Crime stay with long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie